voici la vidéo qui a vraiment fait
connaître wikileaks
c'était en 2006 une bavure militaire
pendant la guerre en irak des images
obtenues grâce à son informateur le
soldat manning
c'était le début d'une vaste fuites de
documents avec l'épisode des aux câbles
diplomatiques 250 mais le télégramme que
le site wikileaks le new york times le
guardian le monde der spiegel el país
cinq grands journaux s'associe à
wikileaks et documente l'envers du décor
de la diplomatie américaine
et il y aura des effets secondaires les
révélations sur le clan ben ali
participe de la colère en tunisie ce
sera l'étincelle du printemps arabe
mais si la saint jean a reçu des
honneurs pour la liberté d'informer
d'autres brosse un portrait plus sombre
du personnage
d'abord les documents secrets mettrait
la ville d'agents américains en danger
sur le terrain et puis il y a les
événements de suède où il est arrêté
pour viol
ce qu'il dément il perd son combat
judiciaire et se réfugie en 2012 à
l'ambassade d'équateur à londres reclus
avec son chat dans une trentaine de
mètres carrés s'il sort c'est
l'arrestation immédiate
d'où son soulagement cinq ans plus tard
quand la suède abandonne les accusations
et puis il ya le rôle trouble de
wikileaks lors de la dernière
présidentielle américaine
je n'avais pas l'intention de faire du
mal à hillary clinton dit il et pourtant
wikileaks à l'avs donald run utilisent
les 20000 courriels piratés du parti
démocrate pour dénigrer sa rivale
certaines agences américaines ainsi que
le procureur muller voient la main de la
russie derrière cette fuite
julian assange est désormais inculpé
d'avoir aidé de chelsea manning pour le
piratage de 2010 il risque pour
l'instant cinq ans de prison
mais d'autres accusations plus graves
pourraient s'ajouter s'il est extradé
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal